[Musique]
karine thérèse bonjour bonjour bonjour à
tous vous êtes candidate europe ecologie
les verts dans le sud absolument c'est
votre première participation à une
élection législative qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui vous motive alors comme
tout martiniquais je constate que la
situation du pays se dégrade nous
constatons tous que le pouvoir d'achat
l'économie le respect
du citoyen en général de la part des
pouvoirs publics est complètement
déséquilibrée et donc face à l'injustice
et aux incertitudes sur l'avenir j'ai
décidé de me présenter pour représenter
mes compatriotes dix sept femmes sur 55
candidats sim 3 de moins qu'en 2010 est
qu'est-ce que cela vous inspire j'aurais
aimé qu'il y ait plus de femmes en
réalité quand on voit le ratio de
nombres de fermat martinique par rapport
aux nombres de monde aurait dû être bien
plus nombreuses et être plus enfance
dans la représentation politique
d'ailleurs et partout ailleurs
vous êtes jeunes vous êtes déjà élu dans
une commune vous êtes déjà présenté une
autre élection alors j'ai été co
listière
dans l'équipe miche ans matinik aux
côtés de yan monplaisir j'avais été
recruté par sylvie assailli soutane que
je salue et que je remet ainsi et c'est
d'ailleurs une femme d'exception qui m'a
inspiré pour me lancer en politique
pourquoi europe ecologie les verts parce
que vous passez demi chance matinik à
élever ce n'est pas vraiment la même
branche ce n'est pas vraiment le même
circuit on me chance et plus de droite
l' écologie c'est vraiment plus de
gauche alors je suis sans étiquette à
l'origine je suis plutôt
orientée sur un axe de bienveillance et
d' équilibre pour tous et d'ailleurs
nous étions bien 60% l'analyste denis
chance matinée qu'à être sans étiquette
nous voulions juste apporter notre
pierre à l'édifice et pourquoi europe
ecologie les verts c'est parce que la
martinique est particulièrement pour ne
pas dire sur exposé à tous les risques
naturel le volcanique cyclonique
sismique
est bien entendu liée au réchauffement
climatique nous sommes surexposé et il
ya fort à croire d'après les prévisions
que nous soyons parmi les premiers
réfugiés climatiques
donc il nous appartient de défendre
notre nature notre ville que nous aimons
tous afin de la préserver le plus
longtemps que possible et au mieux un
niveau priorités la politique de santé
publique qu'est ce qui ne va pas selon
vous voulez dia
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est-ce qui va parce que
ce sera ce sera plus rapide
par où commencer l'état de l'hôpital qui
est déplorable que ce soient des
professionnels ou les patients nous
sommes tous d'accord sur ce constat
le fait de contester également la
politique des pouvoirs publics pour la
gestion de la crise du coc vide il est
inadmissible que des professionnels de
santé qui ont mis leur famille de côté
pour au début de la crise qui ne
rentraient pas chez eux pour préserver
leurs proches qui ont accepté de
travailler sans matériel sans connaître
le virus avec des sacs poubelles sans
masque soit traitée maintenant comme des
parias ils soient privés de leurs
revenus sous couvert de ne pas accepter
qu'on touche à leur intégrité physique
rien intégré aujourd'hui que tout que tu
me donnes ont terminé de toute urgence
de toute urgence il faudrait les
réintégrer parce que nous voyons bien
que tous les professionnels de santé qui
ont les moyens de partir de la
martinique et toutes les forces vives
d'une manière générale qui ont les
moyens de partir de la martinique pour
aller chercher un avenir meilleur
ailleurs le fonds nous avons des enjeux
démographiques aussi à ce niveau là
vous êtes pour level la politique
vaccinale
dans ce qu'on vide là je suis contre
l'obligation vaccinale et je suis pour
la liberté vaccinale est d'ailleurs je
vais profiter de votre question pour
rebondir sur les propos de brigitte
bourguignon nouvelle ministre de la
santé qui
il a déclaré hier
sur le plateau d'un nouveau confrère
qu'elle était prête pour la vaccination
contre la variole à propos de l'épidémie
de variole du singe qui n'est pas encore
une épidémie et quand on lui a demandé
comment ça vous avez suffisamment de
vaccins pour toute la france mais on
vient tout juste d'en parler elle a dit
non non on a suffisamment de vaccins
pour vacciner les professionels de santé
ça suffit
il nous reste à peine cinq secondes le
pouvoir d'achat mais c'est aussi un
autre thème que vous voulez développer
oui on va toucher à leurs trois de mer
on va aussi toucher aux taxes qui sont
abusives et j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête
avec les taxes sur les produits médicaux
qui vont réduire l'accès aux soins pour
les malades
karine terry's je vous remercie merci à
vous
[Musique]